[Music]
no one's allowed to talk is that it
can't talk no you intimidate them good
god you're a woman
is it better to be feared or respected
and i say
is it too much to ask for both i humbly
present the jericho
to peace
dark now you work for me
what are you building stock
[Music]
your eyes are red your tears for your
lung loss boss tears of joy
i hate job hunting yeah vacation's over
welcome home
so put up the scanner with what happened
over there i have my eyes open
i want to protect the people i put in
harm's way
[Music]
a man with a dozen of these can rule all
of asia
yeah i can fly
let's see if this dog
so the upgrade is complete tell you what
throw a little hot rod red in there
[Music]
good luck
[Music]
let's face it this is not the worst
thing you've caught me doing
[Music]
there's been speculation that i'm
breeding around as a superhero
i'm just not the hero type clearly
[Music]
i've been alone for a long time
not because i want to be
but because until i solve this problem i
have to be
your target is a fugitive from the u.s
government
who stole military secrets this is a
location
snatching grab only live capture
taken
there are aspects of my personality that
i can't control
when i lose control
it's very dangerous to be around me
is
they want it as a weapon and if we let
it go we will never get it back
so if you're taking another crack at him
i want him i could probably arrange
something like that
you ready yeah that's even the playing
field
are you telling me another one of your
bio force experiments has gone away
there's only one thing that can affect
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh it's good to be back the notary's
here
front center i'm sorry he's very
eccentric
i want one no
if you can make god bleed
people will cease to believe in him
they will be blood in the water
in the sharks become
[Music]
all i have to do is sit here and watch
as the world
will consume
our priority is to get the iron man
weapon turned over to the united states
of america
i am iron man the suit and i are one
contrary to popular belief i know
exactly what i'm doing
what what i saw you do to tony stark on
that track
wow you need my resources
i want to make iron man look like an
antique this whole
lone gunslinger acts unnecessary you
don't have to do this alone
[Music]
i hope you're ready
[Music]
mr stark displays textbook narcissism
[Music]
[Music]
it's not easy to do what you did
you made my man look like a bunch of
minimum wage mall cops
that's hurtful would you like to tell me
where you received your training
afghanistan judgment
who are you
[Music]
i have sacrificed much to achieve peace
all
through your arrogance and stupidity you
have opened these peaceful realms and
innocent lives
to the horror
and devastation of war
you are a vain greedy cruel boy
and you are an old man and a fool you're
unworthy
father i now take from you
your power
please open your eyes oh no this is uh
isn't it
where he comes from
your ancestors called it magic
and you call it science i come from a
place where they're one in the same
his fate is in his own hands now
i will end this
rogers stephen
[Music]
just give me a chance sorry son
i'm saving your life
general patton has said that wars are
bought with weapons but they are won by
men we just don't know when to give
up do you i could do this all day
our goal is to create the greatest army
in history i should be going with you
look i know you don't think i can do
this this isn't a back alley steve it's
war
every army begins with one man five
tries
in five different cities i can offer you
a chance
he will be the first in a new breed a
super soldier
why me because of weakness
that wasn't so bad that was penicillin
we are going to win this war because we
have the best men
now let's just stop today
we personally explored adolf hitler
your task won't be simple
who the hell are you
your enemy is not
what you expect
i don't know if i can do this
what do you think
i think it works
you were made to be ruled
in the end
it will be every man for himself
what do we do
we get ready
[Music]
there was an idea to bring
together a group of remarkable people
[Music]
so when we needed them they could fight
the battles
that we never could
gentlemen what are you prepared
to do
no offense but i don't play well with
others big man in a suit armor
take that away what are you uh genius
billionaire playboy philanthropist
if we can't protect the earth
you can be damn sure we'll avenge it
dr banner your work is unparalleled and
i'm a huge fan of the way you
lose control and turn into an enormous
green rage monster
thanks
[Music]
got a lot of apologies to make
nothing's been the same since new york
experience things
and then they're over i can't sleep
and when i do i have nightmares honestly
there's a hundred people who want to
kill me i hope
i can protect the one thing i can't live
without
[Music]
ladies children
some people call me a terrorist
i consider myself a teacher
lesson number one heroes
there is no such thing
[Music]
[Music]
after all this time now you come to
visit me brother
why to mock
i need your help
but i wish i could trust you if you did
you'd be the fool i always took you for
some believe that before the universe
there was nothing
they're wrong there was darkness
and it has survived
[Music]
i gave you my word i would return
for you
we face an enemy turn into a few
known only to one you must be
truly desperate to come to me for help
if we do
nothing they will destroy us you even
think about betraying him i'll kill you
that was from new york i like her
thor your bravery will not ease your
pain
your family your world will be
extinguished
running out of time the very fabric of
reality
will be torn apart
i'll find a way to save us all
[Applause]
all yours
anyone else
most of the intelligence community
doesn't believe he exists
[Music]
the ones that do call him the winter
soldier
he's a ghost you'll never find him
[Music]
i joined shield to protect people
you have to to build a better world
sometimes means
turning the old one down that makes
enemies
[Music]
i was fast
[Music]
strong had a metal arm
are you ready all it takes is one step
people are gonna die i can't let that
happen
captain america needs my help
[Music]
when do we start we just did
price of freedom is high
and it's a price i'm willing to pay
he told me not to trust anyone this is
how it ends
everything goes
[Music]
looks like you're giving the orders now
captain damn right
how do we know the good guys from the
bad guys if they're shooting at you
they're bad
i come from earth a planet of outlaws
my name is peter quill
there's one other name you might know me
by star-lord
who star-lord man legendary outlaw
guys forget it
[Music]
so here we are a thief
two thugs an assassin
and a maniac but we're not going to
stand by as evil wipes out the galaxy
i guess we're stuck together partners
are you telling me the fate of 12
billion people
is in the hands of these criminals oh
i look around you know what i see losers
but life's giving us a chance to do what
something good something bad
a bit of both oh what the hell i don't
got that long a lifespan anyway
[Music]
but you're in love with
[Music]
they call themselves the guardians of
the galaxy
this might not be the best idea
[Music]
i'm
i was designed to save the world
people would look to the sky and see
hope
i'll take that from them first
there's only one path to peace
there are extinction
i tried to create a suit of armor around
the world
but i created something terrible
artificial intelligence
it's called the ultron program i'm sick
of watching people pay for our mistakes
this is why we fight so we can end the
fight and go home
[Music]
well you amazingly failed
here we all are
nothing but our wit and our will save
the world
so stand and fight
no way we all get through this i got no
plans tomorrow night
i'm always picking up after you boys
we can tear them apart
from the inside
[Music]
that's the best you can do
imagine a soldier
the size of an insect
the ultimate secret weapon
if you give god like powers to everyone
it's going to be
chaos so how do we stop him
scott i've been watching you for a while
you're different and i believe everyone
deserves a shot at redemption
do you absolutely
my days of breaking into places and
stealing stuff
are over what do you want me to do
i want you to break into a place and
steal some stuff
makes sense are you ready
to become a hero now
this suit has power
you have to learn how to control it
and these are your greatest allies
you're kind of cute whoa
when you're small you have super human
strength
you like a bullet
so you need to know how to punch you
want to show me how to punch show me how
to party
that's how you punch
you tried to hide your suit from me now
it's gonna blow up in your face
and destroy everyone you care about
scott get out of there
did you think you could stop the future
you're just a thief no
a man man i know it wasn't my idea
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this job we try to save as many people
as we can
[Music]
sometimes that doesn't mean everybody
but you don't give up
[Music]
new york
washington dc
circovia
okay that's enough captain people are
afraid
that's why i'm here
we need to be put in check
whatever form that takes some game i'm
sorry tony
if i see a situation pointed south i
can't ignore it
sometimes i wish i could sometimes i
want to punch you in your perfect
teeth i know we're not perfect
but the safest hands are still our own
[Music]
i was wrong about you
the whole world was wrong about you
[Music]
they're coming for you i'm not the one
that needs to watch their back
this doesn't have to end in a fight tony
you just started a war
down final warning
i could do this all day
all right i've run out of patience
underoos
hey everyone
doctor strange you think you know how
the world works
what if i told you the reality you know
is one of many
this doesn't make any sense not
everything does
not everything has to
through the mystic arts we harness
energy and shape reality
[Music]
we travel great distances in an instant
[Music]
how do i get from here to there how did
you become a doctor
studying practice here's the business
there's a strength to him but is he
ready
[Music]
be careful which path you travel down
strange stronger men than you have
washed away
i am death in pain
you'll die protecting this world
i can't do this there is no other way
i've spent so many years peering
through time
looking for you
uh what's this my mantra
it's the wi-fi password we're not
savages
finally here we go good evening peter
you have 576 possible shooter
combinations
that is awesome
i can keep that suit yeah doesn't fit me
what is our next retreat what next
mission we'll call you
all right that's not a hug i'm just
grabbing the toe for you i'm not there
yet
all right kid good luck out there
hey peter you coming tonight i can
tonight i got the
stark internship what's up guys this
stuff here's my report for tonight
i stopped the grand theft bicycle hey
could you do me a favor hold on to that
is this anybody oh i helped this old
lady and she bought me a churro
so that was nice
i just feel like i could be doing more
wait a minute you guys aren't the real
avengers
hulk gives it away new move i'm working
on
not bad this feels so strange
these weapons are crazy dangerous listen
peter there are people who handle this
sort of thing can't you just be a
friendly
neighborhood spider-man
activating parachute
the world's changing boys it's time we
change too
this is my chance to prove myself we
have a spanish quiz
you gotta get better at this part of the
job
what are you hiding peter
[Music]
i'm just kidding i don't care bye
there's a ton of other subsystems in
here but they're all disabled by the
training wheels protocol you're sick of
mr stark treating me like a kid
but you are a kid yeah a kid who can
stop a bus with his bare hands
[Music]
the fate of the universe lies on your
shoulders
now whatever you do
don't push this button
because that will set off the bomb
immediately and we'll all be dead
now repeat back what i just said i agree
no no that's the button that will kill
everyone
try again i am groot i am groot
uh-huh no
[Music]
showtime a-holes
[Music]
[Music]
does anybody have any tape out there i
want to put some tape over the death
button
nobody has any tape not a single person
has tape
you have an atomic bomb in your bag if
anybody's going to have tape with you
i have to do everything you are wasting
a lot of time
that's a really bad sign i touch someone
i can feel their feelings you feel
love yeah i guess yeah i feel a general
unselfish love for just about everything
no
sexual love no no i don't know
she just told everyone your deepest
darkest secret dude
come on i think you're overreacting a
little bit you must be so embarrassed
to me don't mean to me
[Music]
now i know what you're thinking how did
this happen
well it's a long story
[Music]
is dead
[Music]
[Music]
what have you brought today tell me a
contender
[Music]
it's main event time
[Music]
i give you your
incredible
yes
we know each other he's a friend from
work
oh come on
[Music]
i have seen gods fly
i've seen men build weapons that i
couldn't even imagine
uh-huh i've seen aliens
drop from the sky yeah but i have
never seen anything like this how much
more are you hiding
[Music]
my son it is your time show me my
respect and bow
down you get to decide
what kind of king you are going to be
don't freeze i never freeze
[Music]
the revolution will not be televised
[Music]
show me my respect and bow down
[Music]
what happens now determines what happens
to the rest of the world
the revolution will not be televised
the revolution
there was an idea
to bring together a group of remarkable
people
to see if we could become something more
[Music]
so when they needed us we could fight
the battles
that they never could
in time you will know what it's like to
lose
feel so desperately that you're right
yet to fail
all the same
dread it
run from it destiny still arrives
[Music]
evacuate the city engage all defenses
and get this man a shield
[Music]
fun isn't something one considers when
balancing the universe
but this does put a smile on my face
[Music]
who the hell are you guys
so how long have you been ant-man again
not long it just sort of happened
i wish i could fight bad guys like you
[Music]
i seem to mess it up almost every time
[Applause]
maybe you just need someone watching
your back
like a partner
[Music]
dr penn i actually heard what happened
to you you open up the quantum realm
that's when it's crazy could be ghosts
who like walks through walls and stuff
slowly attack
and now she wants to take over the world
or whatever
who would have believed that in your
hour of need you would turn to us okay
because we robbed you do you remember
that's us
the
ant-man and the wasp teaming up follow
my lead
she seems more intense
[Music]
you go low i'll go high i have wings why
would i go low
we were just tiny
i was partners with hank on a project
called goliath how big did you get
my record 21 feet you
65 feet 65.
if you two are finished comparing sizes
65.
[Music]
so scrolls are the bad guys
and you're a cree a race of noble
warriors
heroes noble warrior heroes
[Music]
your life began the day it nearly ended
we found you with no memory
we made you one of us
so you could live longer stronger
superior you were reborn
i keep having these memories
something in my past is the key to all
of this
you know how to fly this thing we'll see
that's a yes or no question yes
[Music]
would you like to know
what you really are
i think i had a life here what are you
telling me
you've come a long way but you're not as
strong as you think
[Music]
this war is just the beginning
i'm not gonna fight your war
[Music]
i'm gonna end it
[Music]
[Music]
i see the cutest little thing aren't you
cute
and what's your name huh
i'll be back
[Music]
stay on
hey miss potts if you find this
recording
don't feel bad about this part of the
journey is the end
[Music]
just for the record being adrift in
space with zero promise of
rescue is more fun than it sounds
food water ran out four days ago
oxygen will run out tomorrow morning
i'd be it when i drift off
i will dream about you
it's always you
thanos did exactly what he said he was
going to do
he wiped out 50
of all living creatures
we lost all of us
we lost friends we lost family
we lost a part of ourselves
this is the fight of our lives
this is gonna work steve i know it is
because i don't know what i'm going to
do if it doesn't
hi uh is anyone home this is scott lang
we met a few years ago at the airport in
germany
i got really big is this an old message
hey man
i know you don't i know you know that
it's the front door that's me
can you buzz me in
everywhere i go i see his face
i just really miss him yeah i miss him
too
[Music]
i don't think tony would have done what
he did if he didn't know that you were
going to be here after he was gone
you gonna be the next iron man now well
no i don't have time i'm too busy doing
your jobs
oh i'm kidding i'm kidding look keep up
the good work because i
am going on vacation
heads up nick fury's calling you i don't
really want to talk to nixon
why because if you don't talk to him and
i have to talk and i want to talk to him
you sent nick fury to voicemail i gotta
go you do not ghost nick fury
hi dorks what's up we're just talking
about the trip i'm here in st
marco polo's oh i think mj really likes
me i remember
my first one alone
you're a very difficult person to
contact
spiderman
this is mr beck you could have used
someone like you all my world
new world back is from earth just not
ours the snap to our hole in our
dimension
you're saying there's a multiverse we
have a job to do
and you're coming with us
there's got to be someone else you can
use what about thor off world
captain marvel unavailable
but i'm just a friendly neighborhood
spider-man
[ __ ] please you've been to space what
do you want peter
i want to go back on my trip with the
girl who i really like and tell her how
i feel
mj i am spider-man no
of course i'm not i mean it's kind of
obvious
you're right you may not be ready but
this is my responsibility
saving the world requires sacrifice
sometimes people die
the world needs next iron man
you're going to step up or not
[Music]
i gotta get you guys out of here you're
on the jet who are you i work with
spiderman you work for spiderman i work
with spiderman not for spider-man
new plan
[Music]
heavenly shades of night are falling
it's twilight
this is our home now i want us to fit in
oh this is gonna be a gap where did you
two move from
how long have you been married and why
don't you have children yet
our story i think what my wife means to
say is that we've moved for
move from where married when damn it why
oh arthur stop it stop it stop it
stop it
is am i dead
no why would you think that because you
are
we are an unusual couple you know oh i
don't think that was ever in question
[Music]
[Applause]
i tell people my sister moved out west
you're a science teacher
your husband fee renovates houses
you're thinking about moving but you're
gonna wait until the interest rates go
down
that's not my story
before i was an avenger i made mistakes
[Applause]
and a lot of enemies
it's called science taskmaster he
controls the red room
they're manipulated fully conscious but
no choices
i should have come back for you how many
others are there
than us
[Applause]
we have to go back to where it all
started so they never do that to anyone
again
we're family we fight with you
you won't win i've always found the best
to look into the past
okay you got a plan or should i just
stay dug and come but my plan was to
drive us away
where your plan sucks
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose
between what the world wants you to be
be my choice
i'm done running
[Music]
here's what's going to happen natasha
don't slouch i'm not slouching you're
going to get the back hunch
listen to your mother oh my god this i'm
up all right enough
all of you i didn't say anything that's
not fair
[Music]
you